[Music]
that isn't shot of Boston where actress
Laurie Lachlan will be back in court
today for hearing in the College
Admission scandal she and her husband
fashion designer Massimo Jian Uli are
accused of paying bribes to get their
daughters into college of course you
remember this
both have pleaded not guilty to fraud
and money laundering charges Carter
Evans explains why their strategy to be
represented by the same law firm could
backfire in federal court today Laurie
Laughlin and Massimo Jian uli will face
a series of questions from the judge
over the potential implications of
presenting a united legal fight the
concern here is that this law firm
cannot zealously represent Laughlin and
her husband because they might be
pointing fingers at each other the pair
is accused of paying half a million
dollars to get their two daughters
admitted into the University of Southern
California as crew recruits even though
they were not competitive rowers a joint
defense could prevent their attorneys
from using evidence that could be
favorable to one of them if it
implicates the other the benefit for
Lori Loughlin and her husband is that
their strength and having a joint
defense that they'll stand in unity and
saying this is an unfair prosecution the
risk in them sticking together in a
joint defense is that they both could go
down 33 parents have been charged in
connection with paying mastermind Rick
singers organization to get their
children into top universities so far 14
and pleaded guilty including actress
Felicity Huffman
three parents who have already pleaded
guilty will be back in court in two
weeks for sentencing now that includes
actress Felicity Huffman prosecutors
have recommended she spend four months
behind bars Gale Carter thank you